fondant ou feuilleter classique ou
décorer depuis plus de 30 ans des
dizaines de pâtissiers amateurs ou
professionnels ce défi pour tenter
d'obtenir le trophée du meilleur
pithiviers et cette année la gourmandise
a une saveur particulière
elle vient d'obtenir le label site
remarquable du goût une première dans la
région
on l'a obtenue pour la mandret
pithiviers c'est à dire pour la culture
demande qui va nous permettre d'ici
quelques années d'obtenir la op ou li gp
pour notre spécialité dans quelques
années c'est chaud pourrait accueillir
des amandiers
une dizaine d'agriculteurs sont
intéressés pour planter près de 40
hectares pour le moment le pithiverais
compte 300 arbres pour le symbole comme
ici à gives rennes on n'est pas encore
dans le domaine d'une filière parce que
c'est tout le début on peut dire qu'on
est peut-être à titre expérimental mais
en tout cas il n'y a une réelle volonté
de replanter des amandiers dans le
territoire c'est à mendier on espère
qu'un jour nous aurons une production
suffisante pour éviter d'importer de
l'amande de californie ce qui est le cas
actuellement dans cette boulangerie
pâtisserie on utilise entre 500 et 700
kilos de poudre d'amande par an est ce
que la production locale sera
compétitive
suffira-t-elle à satisfaire la demande
les quelques professionnels rencontrés
sont plutôt sceptiques
je pense que sur le
là le fond c'est bien mais est-ce qu'on
va avoir une qualité damon égale à celle
qu'on a au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça c'est le grand point d'interrogation
contenu que le climat n'est pas
approprié on est quand même à pithiviers
loin du soleil de la californie ou de la
turquie
les amoureux du pithiviers rêve d'une
filière amende local et d'un label doré
dans quelques années une pleine
production ces cinq ans après la
plantation